activism today can take many different
forms
sucio Park works with defectors from
North Korea to accelerate change in the
dictatorship North Korean people don't
have a hope to gather and naturally make
a change
nemco ally leads a global campaign to
end the barbaric practice of female
genital mutilation the female anatomy is
very much policed by culture and
religion around the world it doesn't
matter whether you're Somali whether
you're prettiest African or even living
in East London
Richard Ratcliffe campaigns for the
release of his wife from an Iranian
prison for me the most important part of
my activism is is campaigning it's
speaking out it's raising Lazarus story
to the world at large three different
activists talk about their campaigns and
what they think it takes to be an
activist in the 21st century
if you look at activism around the world
there seems to be an amazing sort of
flowering of different approaches being
taken to tackle these these deep-seated
problems what does it take to bring
about change in today's world so I think
that one of the key conditions is hope
and momentum and that is something that
the North Korean government has been so
effective in denying North Korean people
that you can work with North Korean
people to undermine the North Korean
government's control or degrade their
ideologies and so that can look like
different methods to get information and
foreign media and so on so the North
Korean people want to make way means
that our organization does it is by
working with North Koreans who are
leaving the country so when you're on a
column refugees the faxes or exile
working with North Koreans who have left
in order to try and empower them as
agents of change back into the country
so we try and build a platform for North
Koreans who have left the country to use
their voice so that the world can see
North Korea is not just Kim jong-un and
my sales but see them see North Korea as
a country from the perspective of North
Korean people which i think is so
lacking in the conversation about that
issue okay to you
nemco Ali's activism grew from her
personal experience as a survivor of
female genital mutilation or FGM
I mean breaking the silence has been a
fundamental basis of my activism and not
being ashamed of something that happened
to me but really trying to get the world
to understand that and for me it was
about lobby in the systems around the
issues of FGM because they were very
much British girls like me who would be
subjected to the practice but now it's
about supporting the efforts and their
movements so I think that's been the
connections between the personal
endeavor to the fire foundation which is
a global activism program to really
ensure that we end FGM and by 2030 okay
and what form does the activity of the
foundation take so what can you actually
do on the ground what are the what are
the tactics in practice so the
fundamental role of the Phi Foundation
is a global partnership the work to n
FGM is being done by women on the
frontline in Africa so so what I do
personally is to elevate those stories
to get the public finance and public and
private sectors in order to invest in
that so for us so for me is to be an
advocate on behalf of the women that are
really doing the work
Richard that's come to you now Richard
rackleff became an activist in 2016 when
his wife nazaneen-e hari rackleff was
accused of plotting to overthrow the
iranian government i stumbled into this
was a middle-aged accountant madly my
wife was arrested on holiday and we've
month muddled our way through it you
know part of being an activist is being
belligerent and difficult sinensis the
well doesn't have to be like this this
is nonsense and just to keep battling
away and and for me that's changed over
time you know an order flight it's just
getting noticed and if there's kind of a
creative anarchy the whole time of
looking for different things to do so
for instance recently someone we had a
hunger strike that we didn't plan on
doing it just doesn't it wasn't one I
joined her we set up in front of the
Iranian embassy to do it and actually
then lots of support it wasn't asked
came along and started decorating the
walls of the embassy with post-it notes
that they'd seen that guys in new in
Hong Kong doing and there was a way in
which actually you know a lot of
campaigning is is making it up as you go
along just to keep on try and keep on
hoping keep on back and keep on being
clear that listen you know welded notice
this is not acceptable the authorities
won't and and your job is to be
belligerent so I'm grateful so you have
to so you have to constantly change
tactics is it sort of part of there's no
right way of doing this yeah you know
you can try something it'll work for a
while and then it won't work some things
will work much better than expected some
things will not work
some things will not work and then will
work and there's a lot of sort of just
patience and an energy the most
important thing is to keep that hope
that it you know the world can be
different the world should be different
and you know by god will I make it